[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
mitri sirin schönen samstagabend ihnen
allen christine sportliches jahr einiges
los fußball-bundesliga und es gibt mit
allem bei der kanu-wm vor allem der ball
rollt wie der guten abend später mehr
dann schauen wir uns jetzt an was wir
außerdem haben
eskalation in nahost nach massiven
raketenbeschuss durch militante
palästinenser
antwortet israel mit erneuten angriffen
im gazastreifen
neue phase im ukraine krieg russland
verlagert offenbar große truppenteile
nach süden gefahr für das atomkraftwerk
sapori cia
und wieder bock auf heavy metal auf dem
wacken festival feiern nach zwei jahren
corona pause
75.000 fans
mehr als ein jahr lang herrschte
einigermaßen ruhe zwischen israel und
den palästinensern
spätestens seit gestern ist das vorbei
seitdem fliegt das israelische militär
luftangriffe im gazastreifen
ein präziser anti terror einsatz sagt
die regierung mindestens 15 menschen
sollen dabei ums leben gekommen sein aus
gaza wiederum werden raketen richtung
israel abgefeuert
über den neuerlichen gewaltausbruch
andreas künast
sie wissen dass sie 30 sekunden haben
von der sirene bis zum möglichen
einschlag wie hier in aschkelon brennt
der halbe süden israels vergangene nacht
in die schutzräume zum ersten mal wieder
seit mehr als einem jahr
seit 24 stunden steigen im gazastreifen
raketen auf überall im südlichen israel
beobachten anwohner wie die meisten von
ihnen abgefangen werden
gestern veröffentlicht israels militär
diese bilder luftangriff auf teile der
führung des extremistischen islamischen
jihad auch deren militärchef
kabarett kommt ums leben nach
palästinensischen angaben starben auch
zivilisten darunter ein fünfjähriges
kind
die lage im krankenhaus ist schwierig
wir haben verwundete in ernstem zustand
vier oder fünf schweben in lebensgefahr
den getöteten kommandeur macht israel
für zahlreiche angriffe aus dem
gazastreifen verantwortlich der
islamische dschihad ist ihr die
zweitstärkste kraft noch radikaler als
die hamas und noch enger mit israels
erzfeind iran verbunden
israel hat eine präzise anti terror
operation gegen eine unmittelbare
bedrohung durchgeführt nicht gegen das
volk von gaza die
israelischen angriffe treffen auch heute
einrichtungen des islamischen jihad
erste vermittlungsbemühungen zum
beispiel ägyptens haben begonnen
lassen wir uns die situation einschätzen
mit andreas kühlers zu in tel aviv
andreas nach langer zeit knallte es
wieder in gaza dazu beidseitig
martialische töne bleibt es beim
schlagabtausch oder droht jetzt wieder
krieg
also die sorge vor einem krieg die ist
auf jeden fall spürbar hier in tel aviv
sogar hat es zum ersten mal seit einem
jahr wieder raketen alarm gegeben wir
konnten die detonationen der
abwehrraketen des sogenannten iron dome
hören ob es zum krieg kommt hängt nicht
nur von israel ab und nicht nur von
dieser extremisten organisation
islamischer jihad sondern auch von der
stärksten kraft im gazastreifen von der
hamas nach allem was heraus trinkt aus
gaza ist hamas an der bisherigen
eskalation nicht beteiligt und nach
allem was herausbringt aus der
israelischen regierung ist die hoffnung
dass das so bleibt das israelische
sicherheitskabinett wird sich hier in
tel aviv noch heute abend treffen und
wohl das zeichen setzen dass israel
bereit ist die operation erst mal
fortzusetzen danke für die
einschätzungen alles gute nach tel aviv
andreas künast
während die welt ein neues atomares
wettrüsten fürchtet bekommt das gedenken
an den atombombenabwurf über hiroshima
in diesem jahr eine besondere bedeutung
mit einer schweigeminute wurde der mehr
als
140.000 opfer gedacht genau 77 jahre
nachdem die usa die erste atombombe
weltweit eingesetzt haben
un-generalsekretär forderte die
abschaffung aller atomwaffen die
weltspiele mit einer geladenen waffe
vor einem nuklearen zwischenfall in der
ukraine waren die internationale
atomenergiebehörde die lage am
atomkraftwerk sabrina sei außer
kontrolle
gestern gab es rund um die anlage
beschuss einer der reaktoren wurde
daraufhin heruntergefahren mit sechs
blöcken ist sabrina das größte
atomkraftwerk europas mitte der 80er
ging es ans netz seit mehr als wird es
von russischen truppen kontrolliert laut
britischem verteidigungsministerium
verlagert moskau derzeit große
truppenteile nach südwesten parallel zum
fluss die mikro und damit richtung
sabrina niebergall
dunkler rauch über dem größten
atomkraftwerk europas wehren wasserstoff
oder radioaktive teilchen ausgetreten
die folgen hätten verheerend sein können
die besetzer haben eine weitere extrem
riskante situation für alle in europa
geschaffen sie haben auf das
atomkraftwerk buschehr geschossen jeder
beschuss dieser einrichtung ist ein
offenes dreistes verbrechen ein
terrorakt
so war es roten aggro die ukraine sagt
seit märz haben sich russische truppen
auf dem gelände verschanzt nutzen es als
militärbasis und schutzschild während
die reaktoren weiter in betrieb sind
haben sie es also selbst beschossen
russland weist die vorwürfe zurück und
erklärt stattdessen bewaffnete
ukrainische gruppen führten drei
artillerie schläger auf dem gelände des
kernkraftwerks abriss und in der stadt
eruh daraus
eine oder arbeiteten früher viele
menschen für das atomkraftwerk manche
tun es immer noch jetzt haben sie angst
davor
klar das ist sehr gefährlich es könnte
ein neues tschernobyl werden oder
schlimmer
als russische truppen sapori schmerz
beschossen trafen sie glücklicherweise
keinen reaktorblock die
atomenergiebehörde waren die technik sei
veraltet kämpfe sehr gefährlich auf
militärexperten sehen grund zur sorge
die russische armee verwendet das
kraftwerk erster linie als
munitionslager weiß eben weiß dass die
ukrainische armee die in den vergangenen
wochen die russischen munitionslager
systematisch angegriffen hat hemmungen
haben wird das akw selber anzugreifen
und durch eine explosion der munition
das akw zu riskieren die dicken
betonwände seien normalerweise auch vor
beschuss gut geschützt einer großen
explosion aber würden sie womöglich
nicht standhalten
wie kann in einem land im krieg so etwas
wie alltag gelingen viele menschen in
der ukraine hoffen auf normalität und
doch leben sieht in ständiger angst vor
russischen angriffen unsere reporterin
anne brühl war im süden des landes
unterwegs hier ihr bericht über eine
kirchengemeinde in nikolajew nur wenige
kilometer von der front entfernt
sie bieten um gottes hilfe darum dass er
ihnen beisteht in zeiten des kriegs
morgenmesse in der griechisch
katholischen kirche von nikolov sie
findet im keller statt der sicherheit
wegen
unsere söhne sind an der front
wir glauben an den himmel wir glauben an
gott und daran dass unser volk endlich
frei sein wird
du weißt nie ob du die nacht überlebt ob
es raketenangriff vergibt oder nicht
während des gottesdienstes gab es einen
neuen angriff der rauch über der
einschlagstelle ist von der kirche gut
zu sehen die gemeinde verteilt
hilfspakete der caritas bezahlt mit
spenden auch aus deutschland
gott sei dank dass die europäischen
länder uns helfen aber ich würde sagen
dass es auch ihre pflicht ist denn wenn
die ukraine nicht gewinnt dann kommt der
krieg nach europa
der priester nimmt uns mit zu
flüchtlingen die auf die
lebensmittelpakete angewiesen sind
vorbei an einem frischen ein schlag vor
einem wohnhaus
lubowski wartet schon auf uns durch ihr
heimatdorf erzählt sie uns verläuft
jetzt die front
erst war es hier ruhig aber jetzt hören
wir die bombardements auch hier wir sind
nervös können das nicht mehr ertragen
wir haben einfach keinen ort an denen
wir gehen können
durch die spenden der caritas hat sie
reis bohnen und öl sicherheit aber die
gibt es in mikulov nicht
knapp ein jahr nach dem vorzeitigen und
chaotischen abzug der nato-truppen aus
afghanistan sind 17
1556 afghanische ortskräfte und ihre
angehörigen nach deutschland eingereist
das berichtet die welt am sonntag und
beruft sich auf behördenangaben für
weitere 6000 menschen gibt es demnach
eine aufnahme zusage nach dem
bundeswehrabzug richteten sich schwere
vorwürfe gegen die bundesregierung weil
sehr viele ortskräfte zurückgelassen
worden waren
angesichts drohender energieengpässe im
winter werden die appelle zum
energiesparen immer lauter die
verbraucher sollten mindestens 20
prozent einsparen sagte der chef der
bundesnetzagentur klaus müller in einem
interview
deutschlands oberste
verbraucherschützerin ramona pop mahnte
ebenfalls zu sparmaßnahmen forderte
stärkere entlastungen für ärmere
menschen
seitdem das gas knapp wird nimmt in
deutschland die diskussion über eine
verlängerung der laufzeiten für
atomkraftwerke wieder vater drei
atommeiler sind noch am netz unter
anderem neckarwestheim 2 in
baden-württemberg die politische
diskussion weckt hier neue
wirtschaftliche hoffnungen bei den
einwohnern antonioni fasst die debatte
zusammen ein atomkraftwerk vor der
haustür die bürger der schwäbischen
gemeinde neckarwestheim kreis heilbronn
leben seit den 1970 er jahren damit das
kraftwerk des energiekonzerns enbw hat
reichlich geld in die kasse gespült und
die kommune hat immer investiert sagt
der bürgermeister man kann da manche
dinge vielleicht bauen die sag ich mal
nicht so die kragenweite von so einem
kleinen ort sind das ist auch
überregional bedeutsam und nach das war
eine tolle zeit sage ich mal von
neckarwestheim
jetzt muss man hier kleinere brötchen
backen denn die geldquelle atomstrom ist
versiegt und die meisten unternehmer im
dorf wie holger mulock haben sich längst
andere kunden gesucht es war ja lange
zeit angekündigt und behauptet man als
unternehmer muss man sich einfach darauf
einstellung muss man damit leben können
dass man so ein großer kunde wegbricht
es wird natürlich den ein oder anderen
feld härter treffen viele die hier leben
haben im oder durch das kraftwerk ihr
geld verdient atomkraftgegner sucht man
hier deshalb vergeblich und die
diskussionen um eine
laufzeitverlängerung haben hoffnungen
geweckt ich bin tatsächlich dafür sogar
dass es noch nicht schließt weil derzeit
mit der energieknappheit gas und so
würden sie sicherlich ein großes problem
werden ich glaubte projektes novelle
angst haben sie keine website euch
sicherer geworden nun übers aber das
atomkraftwerk neckarwestheim wird vom
netz gehen so will es das gesetz es kann
sich nur noch um monate handeln der
abbau wird dann jahrzehnte dauern aber
die neue zeit die hat hier in dem
kleinen weindorf im kreis heilbronn
schon längst begonnen
nach der pandemie pause haben sie in
hamburg wieder die christopher street
day parade gefeiert und das mit
rekordbeteiligung laut veranstalter
waren rund eine viertelmillion menschen
dabei bunte feierstimmung bei bestem
sommerwetter und doch ein ernstes
anliegen unter dem motto auf die straße
vielfalt statt gewalt fordern sie ihre
menschen besser vor einschüchterung und
hass zu schützen
wacken ist eigentlich ein idyllisches
dorf im hohen norden mit knapp 2000
einwohnern es verwandelt sich einmal im
jahr in eine riesige heavy metal party
rund 75.000 fans sollen es in diesem
jahr gewesen sein sagen die
festivalmacher nach zwei jahren corona
pause klingelt wieder in den kassen auch
in denen der anwohner und für die ist
heavy metal längst gesellschaftsfähig
mittendrin glas thoms
warten 2022 es mutet an wie eine
erlösung der metal fans auf dem platten
land endlich nach zwei jahren pause
wieder headbangen tanzen oder einfach
nur lebensfreude ausstrahlt
staubig ist es in diesem jahr die
alternative der berüchtigte schlamm bei
regenwetter bleibt aus egal hauptsache
dreck denn der gehört zum
gesamtkunstwerk
ein
bisschen zu viel chaos mit stundenlang
warteten verursacht die neue bargeldlose
zahlung für bier und pommes und die
organisation der anreise auch die per
bahn und shuttlebus
doch ob kreatives chaos auf den
campingplätzen feiern mit einheimischen
volkstümliches musizieren der
feuerwehrkapelle oder matter yoga im
staub des sogenannten hooligans von
button überall zeigt sich der eigene
charakter bis wir sind alle zusammen und
jeder mag sich und es gibt kein stress
und wenn jemand im moshpit räte wird
aufgehoben die community allgemein
eigentlich nebensache
einfach mal sein die man will abschalten
ein paar chaotische tage im august für
manche das bad
so wir machen ja sportlich weiter mit
christi fußball bundesliga warten erst
mal gute nachrichten vom kanu sport
weltmeisterschaft es gab schon fünf
medaillen aber noch keine goldene erster
finaltag bei der wm im kanadischen
halifax mit zweimal silber und dreimal
bronze für die deutsche flotte dabei
verpasste auch der neu besetzte stets
favorisierte viererkajak der männer im
nacholympischen jahr den sieg
diesmal unterliegen die vier deutschen
ihren rivalen aus spanien die sie in
tokio noch besiegen konnten damals
allerdings mit roland raue jetzt sitzt
johannes schöpf im boot mit max
rendschmidt tom liebscher und max lemke
die von zwischenrang 3 noch aufholen und
silber vor der ukraine erkämpfen spanien
aber heute zu stark deutlich der
rückstand des deutschen cracks
silber auch für nico pickert aus leipzig
im nicht olympischen canadier einer holt
der 24 jährige seine erste wm medaille
und muss sich dabei nur ganz knapp dem
sieger alex milliarde bahn fünf aus
polen geschlagen geben auf den sieger
verliert der sportsoldat nur ein zehntel
bei seinen ersten titel kämpfen
am tag nach dem überragenden 6 1 der
bayern in frankfurt präsentiert sich
auch freiburg zu saisonbeginn der
fußball-bundesliga stark in form in
augsburg gewinnt der sc 4 0 das berliner
derby dominiert union 3 zu 1 gegen die
hertha toller einstieg für daniel farke
mit gladbach 3 2 1 gegen hoffenheim
wolfsburg und aufsteiger bremen trennen
sich 2 2 bochum unterliegt mainz eins zu
zwei das topspiel dortmund leverkusen
ausführlich im sportstudio gestern abend
frankfurts debatte also gegen die bayern
der rekordmeister ist durch die beste
tordifferenz tabellenführer morgen
stuttgart leipzig und köln empfängt
rückkehrer schalke und nach der
niederlage gegen den meister und vor dem
uefa supercup gegen real madrid
frankfurts trainer oliver glasner ist
von 23 uhr 30 an im aktuellen
sportstudio dazu em frauenpower bundes
trainerin martina voss tecklenburg
und torhüterin mehr live roms und auch
in england geht es wieder los die
premier league hat begonnen mit einem
eher mäßigen saisonstart für jürgen
klopp und den fc liverpool beim mutigen
aufsteiger fc fulham lage in der es
zweimal zurück bis mit salat in der 80
minute den ausgleich zum 2 2-endstand
erzielte das beste an diesem spiel ist
das ergebnis so jürgen klopp nach dem
punktgewinn erleichtert ja einfach glück
gehabt würde ich sagen dann fiel dank
christin morgen ist es meist ruhig und
sonnig mehr zum wetter gibt es gleich
mit christa worden das heute journal mit
christian sievers heute um 23 uhr 15 uns
gibt's morgen wieder danke fürs
zuschauen und noch einen entspannten
samstagabend für sie
[Musik]
guten abend es war richtig cool heute
nacht eslohe im sauerland da gab es
heute morgen kurz vor sonnenaufgang fünf
grad dass man nochmal drei grad kühler
als gestern morgen quickborn in
schleswig-holstein da waren wir gestern
morgen noch zweistellig mit zehn grad
heute morgen sind es nur sechs grad
gewesen und rheinstetten bei karlsruhe
da war die tropische nacht von gestern
heute auch geschichte und die kommende
nacht ist ebenfalls zum durchatmen zum
durchlüften ist kühlt ab auf 15 bis 8
grad dazu lässt der schauerartiger regen
im südosten langsam nach oft klar dass
auf aber es kommen neue wolken in den
norden gezogen die sind auch morgen dann
noch in schleswig holstein und im
ostseeumfeld etwas dichter meist bleibt
es aber trocken oft scheint die sonne
von früh bis spät ganz im süden gibt es
quellwolken nachmittags aber auch hier
kaum ein schauer dazu 20 bis 25 grad im
norden im süden 23 bis 29 grad und
anders als heute sind die 30 grad
vereinzelt im südwesten wieder möglich
denn mit diesem hochdruckeinfluss geht
es jetzt auch in den nächsten tagen
weiter viel sonne lockere wolken im
norden und im osten deutschlands und die
temperaturen steigen wieder an der
temperatur trend von köln zeigt uns zum
nächsten wochenende wieder um die 35
grad und auch die nachttemperaturen die
halten wieder auf tropische 20 grad zu
das war es von uns